non à 20h50 on dirait de ce qui est
arrivé la nuit dernière à Bruno Guillon
l'animateur de France 2 et Fun Radio qui
a été menacé avec une arme séquestrée sa
femme a été ligotée vous allez voir ce
qui s'est passé c'est extrêmement
violent on va toujours raconter dans un
instant avec notamment Réda Bella donc
secrétaire départementale unités LGP
police et David descot ex cambrioleur de
célébrités anciens détenus qui va nous
dire aussi comment ça se passe parce que
c'est vrai que c'est quand même ça
devient de plus en plus courant
les chéris il y avait Bernard Tapie il y
a eu kim Kardashian il y a eu Aya
Nakamura et le chantage à la sextape
également Kenji et Benoît Magimel à
quelques heures d'intervalle qui sont
fait Jonathan Cohen aussi l'avait très
mal vécu il a mal vécu son cambriolage
il y en avait parlé lors d'une promo
aussi il y a quelques années il y a les
sportifs également donnaruma le joueur
du PSG cambriolé séquestré et ligoté on
va parler de tout ça parce que il y a
Cyril gagne aussi mon ami Cyril du MMA
qui a été cambriolé alors qu'il
combattait lui et c'est vrai que voilà
il y a de plus en plus ce n'est pas des
c'est des cambriolages mais c'est
surtout et séquestration voilà et très
violente on va raconter une histoire de
Bruno Guillon dans un instant mais juste
je voulais qu'on vienne sur vous
rappeler tous de cette histoire de Kim
Kardashian ou de Nabilla je voudrais
qu'on vienne aussi sur rappeler la star
de télé-réalité Maëva gaina qui a été
victime aussi de deux hommes se sont
introduits chez elle et moi tenté de
mettre le feu à sa maison rappelez-vous
on est là
il faut que j'appelle le centre il va me
les envoyer
ils sont rentrés dans ma maison frère
voilà ça c'était moins grave voilà que
ce qui s'est passé pour Bruno Guillon
merci Reda d'être avec nous merci David
Desclos je voudrais voir déjà avant
qu'on vous raconte l'histoire de de
Bruno Guillaume qui est incroyable qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui un cambriolage
chez une star David vous êtes
cambrioleur de célébrité on le sait
maintenant que tu étais sur scène ancien
détenu c'est efficace à 100%
généralement oui généralement oui parce
que il y a au minimum des bijoux il y a
des objets de valeur au minimum des sacs
des enfin tout ce qui est obligé de
valeur donc généralement oui mais ce qui
se dit maintenant ce qu'il faut vraiment
dire c'est que il y a peut-être même
plus à prendre chez les stars que dans
les banques dans les banques il y a plus
d'argent et donc tous ceux qui
s'attaquaient aux banques à l'époque bah
on laissait tomber des banques et passe
à ce style de cambriolage de de braquage
alors est-ce que toi tu as déjà
cambriolé le domicile d'une star par
exemple oui j'en suis pas fier mais
c'est vrai que
deux fois la troisième j'ai pas voulu et
il y en a une que je peux le dire voilà
c'est parce que ça s'est bien fini c'est
une belle histoire c'est c'est chez
Monsieur Jean-Paul Belmondo donc il y a
ça c'est bien fini on va te cambrioler
Jean-Paul Belmondo en fait moi à cette
époque là c'était voilà c'était les
secteurs Saint-Germain-des-Prés rue des
Saints-Pères tout ça on savait donc
c'est à cette épreuve on allait dans
dans les endroits où on savait qu'il y
avait de l'argent et tout et donc voilà
je traînais par là-bas donc je moi
j'avais fait mes repérages et puis comme
j'étais moi j'étais sans arme sans
violence j'étais un Arsène Lupin j'étais
le spécialiste de la faille l'avait
voilà rentrer sans qu'on me voit
ressortir sans qu'on voit c'était
c'était ça donc
j'avais malheureusement je m'étais ce
don dans du mauvais côté de la barrière
et donc ça m'était entre guillemets
facile de faire ça et donc comme je l'ai
dit comme
d'aller dans les endroits où j'étais
susceptible de trouver beaucoup d'argent
et par exemple est-ce que vous repérez
comment ça se passe les repérages c'est
quoi c'est par rapport aux voitures ou
vous pensez que on va on va revenir sur
l'histoire d'un instant penser que les
ceux qui ont fait ça à Bruno Guillon
est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils ont repéré
depuis longtemps qui savait que c'était
un mec de télé etc ou pas du tout moi
pour moi c'est un coup soit qui a été
donné d'accord avant tout autre chose je
voudrais quand même dire aussi juste une
petite phrase dire que je condamne
complètement
au contraire il est dans la rue voilà
j'apporte vraiment mon soutien voilà
c'est un ami moi on va me reprocher
d'être ton ami dans dans complètement
d'enquête bien sûr
d'ancien détenus mais voilà tu es un ami
et je sais que tu sais comme comme pour
moi et voilà mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui voilà tu es passé voilà
je suis passé voilà mais je voulais
apporter mon soutien et dire que je
Bruno Guillaume tu dis quoi ce que ce
que je suis quasi sûr que ça a été un
coup qui a été donné ensuite il y a eu
des gros repérages des repérages parce
que pour savoir où votre par où passer
repérer la fenêtre
par où passer donc c'est des repérages
succieux et voilà mais c'est millimétré
c'est pas fait n'importe comment c'est
voilà et savoir à quelle heure rentrée
comment quoi et tout est calculé à
l'avance donc quand ils arrivent ils
frappe ils veulent ils veulent ils
veulent pas faire une seule erreur quoi
donc ils y vont moi pourquoi je condamne
ça c'est parce que voilà s'attaquer une
femme et des enfants et des tout ça je
suis contre complètement
ce qu'il faut qu'il fasse attention
c'est ça c'est à qui il parle parce que
c'est des coûts qui sont donnés qui sont
ouais quand sont très très connus des
fois tu regardes sur internet tu peux
trouver les adresses tu peux trouver
avec les réseaux les trucs et tout ça
mais Bruno voilà c'est pas il est connu
mais c'est pas voilà c'est c'est pas un
voilà tu le connaissais tôt
pour ça tu penses que c'est pas voilà
c'est c'est c'est tu penses que quoi
c'est ça a été donné ça a été donné ça a
été donné et voilà ils sont mis dessus
ils voilà et comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure comment donner c'est à dire que
quoi les mecs donner c'est en fait de
connaissances à grimpe je donne un
exemple quelqu'un qui va faire qui un
pote un truc tiens je sais que Bruno
habite là tac et c'est le bouche à
oreille le tu vois le bouchon
on dit tiens ça arrive à l'oreille de
mauvaise personne voilà ça arrive dans
souvent dans les quartiers dans les
cités ça part vous savez il y a un va et
vient dans les quartiers ceux qui
viennent acheter le Toshi qui viennent
acheter la gueule de route et ça ça bout
il y a vraiment un va-et-vient et voilà
ils disent bah tiens je suis où un tel
habite un tel habit voilà les joueurs de
foot sont c'est ça alors on voit qu'il y
a de plus en plus de célébrités qui se
font non pas cambriolé mais plutôt même
cambrioler saucissonner il rentre chez
eux ça commence à se faire ça bah comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure comme il y a
plus d'argent dans les banques les gros
braqueurs les grosses équipes de
braqueurs qui avant braquer les banques
et bien maintenant se rabattre sur ça
parce que comme il dit ils savent qu'ils
vont trouver des bijoux que à la revente
va faire
du fric du liquide des choses donc c'est
pour ça et donc ces braqueurs qui
mettaient tout tout dans les banques à
l'époque on rappelez-vous le gang des
postiche rappelez-vous toutes les toutes
les bandes de braqueurs qui a eu à
l'époque parce que il y en a de moins en
moins vous voyez pas ça on voyait pas ça
avant parce que il y a tellement peu
d'argent et c'est pas une espèce il y a
plus d'espèces tu vas dans une banque
faut s'attaquer aux dab alors mais sinon
il y a plusieurs mois moins dangereux
moins risqué et peut-être plus onéreux
plus avantage plus avantage
le guichet va lui dire excuse-moi mais
il y a plus rien j'ai des papiers j'ai
des enveloppes à te donner si tu veux
rien donc et ben ils ont rabattu leur
truc sur sur ça est-ce que les réseaux
sociaux ça joue aussi pareil que les
mecs voilà parce que on se dit voilà
Bruno il paraît qu'il mettait des vidéos
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux de sa
maison et que c'était enfin de où il
habitait je crois que c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit est-ce que ça ça peut jouer ou pas
bien sûr bien sûr je te le disais tout à
l'heure en priorité check ça regarde les
réseaux les réseaux sociaux les trucs
qui tiennent bon voilà c'est pour ça
qu'il faut faire ça attention à ça et
ensuite ben une connaissance qui va qui
va dire tiens je sais où est un tel
habite et tout ça les deux sont pris et
puis vous avez aussi mais ça j'y crois
pas du tout pour l'affaire de Bruno
Guillon euh ce qui est le coup de chance
déjà j'arrive là je tombe chez lui il
croyez pas du tout du tout
parce que voilà c'est les pourquoi euh
après on va on va vous dire les
circonstances vous allez voir folle de
ce cambriolage qui est vraiment ont dû
vraiment traumatiser toute la famille de
Bruno et Bruno
juste pourquoi ils disent pas on va y
aller quand il y a personne pourquoi ils
se disent on va là ils ont en pleine qui
sont aliciament ils savaient qu'ils
étaient là ils sont dit on va quand même
être dans la violence pourquoi ben parce
que c'est ce style de braqueurs il y a
plusieurs styles de braqueurs et de ou
de cambrioleur vous avez des
cambrioleurs qui vont comme je dis tout
à l'heure qui vont rentrer sans armes
sans violence qui vont être des filous
qui vont être des mains qui vont même ça
je le connais c'est vraiment c'est pas
bien non plus mais vous avez le style de
qui vont qui qui vont eux c'est leur
style ils sont ils ont besoin que les
gens soient là ils braquent et voilà il
faut et puis surtout des fois bah je
sais pas ça l'enquête le dira mais par
exemple il braque le il le font parler
un peu pour ça s'il a pas un coffre chez
lui un coffre à ouvrir et tout ça c'est
voilà
les codes les trucs savoir où il
planquaient de ouh il planque l'argent
parce que ils ont pas le temps ils
bravent il faut que ça aille vite et
donc il faut vite qu'il sache où est
l'oseille et donc ils font peur flingue
sur la tempe dis-moi où tu te plantes ta
thune le gars pour sauver sa femme et
ses jambes il dit vite où est son argent
et voilà alors que si il est pas là le
temps qu'il fouille qui cherche qui
freine il peut ils vont prendre ils vont
pas de ce que tu dis